the family of a murdered military
heroism boiled in an international fight
for justice
Carl Harig was killed in his Ohio home
in March 2007 Eric's family immediately
suspected his wife Claudia she boarded a
flight to her native Brazil just hours
after her husband's death US
investigators charged Claudia with
murder but more than ten years later the
Herrig family is still seeking justice
for tomorrow's 48 hours Erin Moriarty
traveled to Brazil to learn what it will
bring what will take to bring Claudia to
trial here's a preview the way I've
heard him described as fearless is that
yeah Carl Harig was one of those All
American military pilots the real-life
hero revered by Hollywood filmmakers it
looks like a movie star doesn't he he
flew c-130 cargo planes on nearly 200
treacherous combat missions to Iraq in
Afghanistan he had a loving family and a
wide circle of loyal friends what was it
like to fly with Carl he was amazing he
was actually a very good pilot but he
was a better person he was my best
friend
even after you were divorce oh yeah Carl
and his ex-wife Rhonda had two children
brent and eva and he was always close to
his younger brother paul here's your big
brother in 2005
carl had met a brazilian woman named
Claudia they were already planning to
get married I didn't even know he had a
girl but the marriage was rocky from the
start
two years later Carl was murdered in his
own home shot twice in the back and once
in the head at close range
my oldest brother called and told me
What did he say
he said Carl's dead as soon as he said
Carl's dead I already know who did it I
know it was her when investigators
discovered Claudia Herrick have bought a
Magnum 357 revolver the weekend before
she became the prime suspect but Claudia
was nowhere to be found
hours after Carl was shot she boarded a
plane and flew to her native Brazil
she was now out of reach of Ohio
authorities because Brazil won't
extradite its citizens she knew all she
had to do was not get caught until she
got to Brazil and she was home free we
knew it wasn't gonna be easy I don't
think we thought it was going to take
more than ten years you want to go to
Brazil I would love to go to Brazil we
learned Claudia had opened her own
accounting business we're with CBS News
and got a new husband along the way
clearly the woman who was a fugitive
from justice in the u.s. is not living
like one here in Brazil it makes me mad
to know that she was living such a
comfortable life and you know my
brother's dead and the more he learns
about his brother's accused killer makes
Paul Herrick even more determined to
fight for her extradition I'll do
whatever it takes to get the justice for
my brother
[Music]
Wow what a story Erin Moriarty is with
us now Erin good morning so Claudia is a
Brazilian citizen and you say this case
could be groundbreaking why well because
this could be the very first time that a
Brazilian born citizen is actually
extradited by Brazil and here's why she
is a Brazilian citizen where it was but
she also became an American citizen in
1999 and as part of that process which I
did not realize so I started working on
this you have to renounce allegiance to
any other state and so what the US
officials have been saying all along is
wait a minute she gave up her Brazilian
citizenship so she is actually an
American extradite er here's what's
shocking is that the Brazilian courts
have actually agreed and just this month
the Supreme Court said we're done we
have stripped her of her citizenship so
now it's up to the president Brazil so
one step forward to possibly sending her
back to the US you however went to
Brazil were you able to find Claudia oh
we we found Claudia when you see our
report you will see she's changed a
great deal she is trying to stay there
she once actually be tried in Brazil
because if you're tried for murder
convicted of murder you only get 30
years and believe that's or not after
five years of prison you get to work out
in the community Wow and you went to
Brazil
you found your woman Erin Moriarty
that's amazing thank you very much you
can see Erin's full report a brothers
mission on 48 hours tomorrow night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS